>> THE WINTER OF
2015 HAS WREAKED HAVOC ALL OVER
THE NORTHEAST, AND SOME NEW
YORKERS HAVE SEEN THEIR HOMES
DESTROYED BY THE RECENT
BLIZZARD.
STATEN ISLANDERS AIMAN YOUSSEF.
>> IT WAS NOT BLIZZARD.
>> RIGHT. AN ICE STORM.
>> IT WAS NOT AN ICE STORM.
>> FROZEN HAIL?
>> THAT'S NOT IT, EITHER.
IT WAS FROM HURRICANE SANDY.
>> WHAT, THAT WAS LIKE TWO YEARS
AGO.
>> EXACTLY, TWO YEARS AGO, WE'RE
STILL IN A TENT.
>> WHAT?
WE HAD A CONCERT TO HELP.
WE HAD MICK JAGGER THERE AND THE
BOSS WAS THERE AND THEN WE HAD
ANOTHER CONCERT AND THERE WERE
COMMERCIALS AND THIS GUY IS
STILL IN A TENT?
SO THIS IS WHERE YOUR HOUSE USED
TO BE.
>> CORRECT.
>> THIS USED TO BE YOUR LIVING
ROOM?
>> YES.
>> AND HE'S NOT ALONE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
STILL WITHOUT HOMES.
>> NOBODY'S HOME, ME INCLUDED.
>> IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS ALREADY.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN REBUILT.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'RE FROM NEW
YORK.
HOW COULD THIS POSSIBLY TAKE
THIS LONG?
>> OKAY, WAIT, MORE THAN $648
MILLION WAS SET ASIDE FOR AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED BUILD IT
BACK WHICH WAS CREATED SOLELY
TO-- IT'S IN THE NAME-- BUILD
PEOPLE'S HOUSES BACK.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE GUYS?
>> BUILD IT BACK REALLY SUCKS.
>> BUILT IT BACK, THEY BUILD
NOTHING.
>> THEY LOSE PAPERWORK.
IT'S JUST BEEN-- NO ANSWERS, AND
NO PROGRESS.
>> WE HAVE NO HOMES BUT WE PAY
TAXES ON THOSE HOMES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHAT?
>> I'M STILL PAYING
FLOOD INSURANCE.
THEY DIDN'T FINISH PAYING ME,
BUT I AM STILL PAYING THEM.
>> WE NEED TWO FLOORS AND THEY
ONLY WANT TO FINISH ONE.
AND ALL WE WANT IS WHAT WE HAD
BEFORE.
SIMPLE KITCHEN, SIMPLE LIVING
ROOM AND A BATHROOM.
>> WOAH, WOAH, WOAH. WHAT ELSE?
>> DOORS WOULD BE NICE.
>> PLURAL.
>> YEAH, DOORS ON THE BEDROOMS,
MAYBE A FRONT DOOR.
>> YOU SEE HOW THIS COULD TAKE A
WHILE.
IF I DO THE MATH HERE, THIS IS A
17-YEAR PROJECT.
IT'S BECAUSE BUILDING IN NEW
YORK CITY IS COMPLICATED.
JUST ASK ARCHITECT ENRIQUE
NORTON.
>> NEW YORK IS A VERY COMPLEX
CITY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, A LOT
OF THINGS GET BUILT HERE AND A
LOT OF VERY GOOD THINGS GET
BUILT HERE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE RECENTLY
COMPLETED THE MERCEDES HOUSE.
>> NOW HOW LONG DID THIS TAKE TO
COMPLETE?
>> THIS TOOK TO COMPLETE
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEARS.
>> OR JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME THAN THE SANDY VICTIMS ARE
WAITING FOR THEIR HOMES.
>> BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 1.2
MILLION SQUARE FEET.
>> THAT'S NOT 1.2 MILLION SQUARE
FEET.
>> NO, THIS IS ONLY A MODEL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BUILDING.
>> THE ACTUAL BUILDING.
THIS?
>> YEAH, WE DID THIS BUILDING.
>> YOU BUILT THIS IN THREE
YEARS, AND NOTHING, NOTHING IS
GOING ON IN STATEN ISLAND.
UNBELIEVABLE.
UNREAL.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS THE PROBLEM
HERE?
>> BUREAUCRACY IS TO BLAME FOR
NOT REBUILDING HOMES.
>> NOTHING GOOD EVER HAPPENED
WITHOUT BUREAUCRACY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I SAY TO THAT,
RIGHT?
>> WHAT?
>> LET'S GO OUT IN THE BACKYARD,
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
BUREAUCRACY, AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
COMES OUT OF IT.
>> WAIT, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE BACKYARD.
>> WE'RE GOING TO KICK THE
( BLEEP ) OUT OF YOU?
>> WHAT, I THOUGHT WE WERE JUST
GOING TO TALK ABOUT BUREAUCRACY
AND SIGN SOME PAPERS.
OKAY UNDERSTANDABLY, THINGS
WERE GETTING TENSE SO I TURNED
TO LOCAL ADVOCATE ALANA TORNELLO
TO SEE WHAT I COULD DO.
I'M GOING TO DROP THE IRONIC,
HANDSOME JORDAN KLEPPER
CHARACTER, AND I'M JUST
GOING TO BE JUST HANDSOME
JORDAN KLEPPER.
I WANT TO HELP.
WHAT CAN I DO TO HELP?
>> OKAY, DO YOU HAVE ANY SKILLS?
( LAUGHTER )
WELL, YOU DON'T NEED TO HAVE ANY
SKILLS TO COME VOLUNTEER.
>> GREAT.
>> AS THE MEDIA, THERE IS A LOT
THAT CAN BE DONE TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT FOR SOME PEOPLE, FOR
SOME NEW YORKERS, THIS IS STILL
A DISASTER AND THIS IS STILL A
STORY.
>> WHAT?
>> I'M TALKING TO YOU.
THIS IS YOU.
YOU CAN DO THIS.
NOT AS THE MEDIA.
>> OH.
OH!
>> RIGHT. RIGHT.
>> OH
YEAH!
OH RIGHT!
OH, YEAH, THIS THING.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN REMIND PEOPLE
THAT THIS IS STILL A NEWS STORY.
>> DONE.
>> OKAY?
THANKS.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING
HERETO WHOLE TIME.
LOOKS LIKE MY WORK AS A MEDIA
PROFESSIONAL IS DONE.
BUT UNTIL HELP REALLY DOES
ARRIVE, SANDY VICTIMS MAY NEED A
LITTLE PATIENCE, COURTESY OF
STATEN ISLAND'S THIRD MOST
POPULAR GUNS N' ROSES TRIBUTE
BAND.
OH, DON'T, DON'T, DON'T, DON'T
PLAY ACTUAL "PATIENCE."
WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHTS TO
THAT.
♪ I'VE BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY
♪♪
>>, OF COURSE, AFTER TWO AND A
HALF YEARS, THESE GUYS HAVE A
PRETTY SIMPLE MESSAGE FOR ANYONE
WHO THINKS THEY SHOULD WAIT A
LITTLE LONGER.